une deuxième victoire pour julian
assange ce mercredi c'est la question
qui se pose en ce jour d'audience pour
qu'il soit libéré sous caution les
avocats du fondateur de wikileaks
mettent en avant les risques pour leurs
clients de contracter le kovy 19 dans la
prison de belmarsh où il reste détenu
lundi la justice britannique a refusé
d'extrader l'australien aux états unis
pour cause de santé mentale défaillante
et risque de suicide
une première victoire dans cette saga
judiciaire une décision dont ses plus
fidèles soutiens se sont félicités on ne
peut pas célébrer nous célébrerons le
jour où il rentrera à la maison je
demande au président des états unis d'y
mettre fin maintenant monsieur le
président démolissez les murs de cette
prison que nos petits garçons et leur
père libérer julian libérer la presse
libérez nous tous à l'international
également les initiatives ne se sont pas
fait attendre
le président mexicain andres manuel
lopez obrador offre l'asile politique à
julian assange
les séries en seconde nous sommes prêts
à offrir l'asile et nous félicitons la
justice britannique pour sa décision à
la constition d'événement est bon je
suis en faveur d'une grâce des caisses
lnd où le thé etc nous passons j'étais
un journaliste il
mais l'essai et mérite une chance on a
au porto nisa de son côté la fédération
internationale des journalistes exige
dans un communiqué la libération de
julian assange et la levée immédiate de
toutes les charges contre lui soutient
également en france le parti communiste
français a ainsi appelé emmanuel macron
à sortir de son mutisme et à
l'accueillir dans les meilleures
conditions
julian assange est poursuivi par la
justice américaine pour avoir publié
sept cent mille documents classifiés sur
des activités militaires et
diplomatiques dont certaines illégal
notamment en irak et en afghanistan les
etats-unis se préparent à faire appel de
la décision prise lundi
mais il reste une zone d'ombré sur la
réaction de la future administration de
joe biden qui ne s'est pas encore
exprimé sur cette affaire pour rappel
barack obama et son vice président à
l'époque joe biden avait abandonné les
poursuites à l'encontre du journaliste
elle avait été ensuite relancé sous la
présidence de donald trump